today we're going to talk about how to
prepare your life before starting at a
top law school so stick around and get a
head start now it's no secret that law
school is incredibly stressful so many
lawyers I know say that law school was
the worst part of their entire lives now
it doesn't necessarily need to be that
way
you can do yourself a huge favor by
making your life in law school as easy
as possible and here are the best ways
of getting your life in order so that
your life in law school is as good as it
can be so here's my first piece of
advice get an apartment that is as close
to campus as possible I know it's
expensive it can't be helped but if it
was between having roommates and living
far away from campus I would take the
roommates you're making an investment in
law school and if that means that you're
going to have to pay a little bit more
in rent to live closer to campus I would
recommend it
avoiding a commute can save you
literally hours a day and that's time
that you can use to either a study more
or be relaxed both of which are
incredibly important when you get to law
school a friend of mine went to law
school in Los Angeles he lived in West
LA but he went to school in East LA that
means that he had in general a 90 minute
commute each way he lost three hours
every day he went to class now law
school is a marathon it's not a sprint
you want to work a reasonable amount
every day adding an extra hour or two
because your commuting is just a recipe
for disaster so if you can do it I
highly recommend living as close to
campus as possible that brings me to my
next tip get the right technology when
you start now that means a new computer
potentially a tablet a laser printer
these things will make your life so much
easier we have an entire video dedicated
to the tools that I wish I had when I
started law school the technology has
gotten so great there are a lot of good
tablets a lot of good laptops you get a
laptop with solid-state drive one that
has a very long battery life you can
have laptops that last
ten hours at a time not all law schools
have electrical outlets all over the
place so you want a good laptop that
will last you a long time and preferably
one with cloud storage so that you don't
lose your important notes and your
outlines because everyone has a horror
story where they lose that stuff and you
want the peace of mind my next tip is
related to the technology and that is if
you have the time
get your typing speed up while law
school exams are not a brain dump in the
same way that undergrad exams tend to be
you still have a huge premium by being
able to type what you need to type as
quickly as possible you can get more
points simply by virtue of being able to
type faster and more accurately than
your peers if you have some time in the
summer before law school I would say
practice your typing whether it's I
don't know Mavis Beacon or Mario teaches
typing whatever the new typing software
is out there I would use it and get your
typing speed up I'd aim for a hundred
words per minute you will be happy it
will serve you for the rest of your life
being able to type accurately next get
your personal relationships in check
it's a sad fact but most couples break
up during law school if your
relationship is going south honestly
it's better to end it now law school is
a time to focus and if that means ending
a bad relationship do it before you get
to law school because you'll be happy
that you did next deal with your health
law school is stressful and your
priorities are not going to be on
yourself so in the summer before law
school deal with your health ahead of
time get a check-up get a dentist
appointment do it so that you're not
worried about that during your first
year there is no better way to derail
your final than getting sick right
before you take your first exam next
mentally prepare so ahead of time I
would say do a little bit of research
read 1l watch the movie the Paper Chase
you're going to be putting in some long
hours so I would recommend doing some
research ahead of time to find out what
law school is going to be like now
obviously those are
dramatizations they're not entirely
accurate both one L and the Paperchase
take place in the 70s in law school has
changed however it gives you a general
idea of what you're going to face next
and this is especially important learn
how to hack law school doing well in law
school and especially on essay exams is
not a dark art there is a science to it
this is the number one missed
opportunity learning how to take law
school exams don't worry about learning
the law itself there will be plenty of
time in law school to understand torts
and contracts and Civil Procedure in law
school your grades are determined
entirely based on your performance on
your final exam and what's worse is that
it's graded on a curve so the professor
even if he wanted to give out all A's is
limited and can only give out say five
A's per class law school final exams are
almost always issue spotting exams and
issue spotting exams are just like the
LSAT there are strategies and tactics
that can help you do better and the more
you practice the better you get at them
so it's so important to learn how to
take law school exams at legal eagle we
offer an entire course on how to take
issue spotting exams additionally use
the time before law school to get your
resume your letters of rec and your
references in order what nobody tells
you about law school is that you're
going to apply for your summer jobs in
the middle of your 1l year it can be
incredibly stressful because you're
preparing for exams that you've never
seen before you're learning law that you
have no frame of reference for and in
the middle of that you still have to
apply for jobs during the summer so
those are the best ways to get your life
in order before you start law school you
can do yourself a huge favor by making
small tweaks it will make a huge
difference in your law school career law
school is stressful enough the last
thing you want to do is not prepare
ahead of time for things that could have
a huge impact during your law school
career so remember from everyone here at
legal
you'll study smart through law school oh
and one last thing if you're getting
ready for law school check this out we
put together a free ebook called the
ultimate pre-law checklist just click
the link below to download it if some of
our best tips and strategies for getting
ahead before you start law school and it
will put new miles ahead of your
classmates just click below and also if
you like this video please subscribe to
our Channel we come out with new videos
on how to crush law school all the time
so thanks a lot thanks for stopping by
[Music]
[Music]